the power story class is really fun to
teach and I think it's also fun to take
the reality is that storytelling is not
new and in fact we were good
storytellers when we were all kids and
yet somehow we lose the ability to tell
stories in persuasive ways over the
course of time what this class does is
not only illuminate what is a good story
and what is a bad story it helps the
audience figure out how to tell stories
more effectively particularly with the
context of business and mind so how do
you use stories to grow your business
how do you use stories to persuade
stakeholders to engage with you to be
part of your brand to help you build
your brand to come on board
we provide a framework for people to
understand how to tell a great story and
briefly that framework is you have to
have a single focus school
why are you developing the signature
story for your business what do you want
the audience to do after you share that
story the second is how do you grab
attention how do you create a hook for
the story why would someone even want to
listen
third is engagement why would the why
would the audience even want to care so
there we talked about the protagonist
and characters and the arc of the story
these are all tools that you have to
deepen the relationship you have with
your audience and then the fourth is
enable action what do you want the
audience not just to do but when my
phase share the story that you just
shared with them what would they do with
the story that would allow it to grow
storytelling is a tool to be used with
stakeholders like your board you can
imagine any board meeting that you run
starting or ending with a story it's
also a tool to be used for customers to
not only explain more what the brand
stands for and why but also to get them
on board and become marketers of your
brand and it's also a tool to be used
for employees and it doesn't matter if
it's a startup or a big organization
story is an incredibly powerful tool
that many of us don't use and yet can be
an incredibly potent
the most important thing is a better
understanding of story when is it
powerful tool that you can use to
persuade to create action there is a
secondary goal and that is actual
practice with storytelling what
individuals get outside of this class or
after this class is real practical
hands-on insight on how they can improve
their own storytelling skills what the
participant of this course will get is
not only insight into what makes a great
story versus a poor story but actual
practice at storytelling so what they'll
get after the course is hands on insight
on their own storytelling skills and in
fact an actual story at the end of the
class